man of the hour huh I don't know man
there's a few of us yeah a few men and
women of the hours for days the weeks
the months the years the life you know
something tells me you weren't wearing a
tux during the holidays how's it feel to
be dressed up tonight in celebration of
this amazing film here in Palm Springs
oh this is just casual Thursday is it
Thursday it is Thursday
um it's lovely to be here I was here
five years ago to give Sam Rockwell my
old buddy Sam his desert whatever I lose
I lose track of what they are mine's
desert achievement I believe Desert Palm
achievement
um so I was here five years ago I had a
great time with Sam I was here to honor
Sam and he's doing me a solid he's
coming back to return yeah yeah yeah
he's going to give me the thing tonight
so it's lovely it's lovely to be here
man it's lovely to be here to support
the film as well so many people worked
so hard on and of course I mean it's
also must be nice to know that you
already won you don't have to sit here
and worry yeah I still reserve the right
to be surprised that I'm here though
truly do you feel surprised yeah you
know I've been around a while you have
and you've had so many memorable
performances you have a lot of folks
saying this is your career best what
does it feel like and what does it mean
to you to hear that it feels like I
didn't work any harder on this than I
worked on anything over the last 25
years honestly I mean
different projects ask of different
things from you so maybe this asks a
little bit more Mark McDon is an
extraordinary writer and he writes from
a place of great depth and Imagination
so it's lovely man I try not to look the
gift horse in the mouth too much I can
get into kicking over sandcastles a bit
easy for me so my kid was like Dad just
enjoy it so I'm trying to lean into his
wisdom as you should right you can't
overthink it I don't think you can you
know a lot this past year we also got to
see you in the Batman of course as a
penguin that series is set for HBO Max
soon yeah I mean how's are you prepared
to go under those Prosthetics again I
mean most the preparation for that one
is with Mike Moreno and his team Mike
who designed the makeup and is an
extraordinary artist and an absolute
genius a word that's batted around way
too often of course but Mike is the real
deal so I'm excited to I loved working
on that film but I only had six or seven
scenes and I was kind of greedy I wanted
more and more and more so I'm going to
get my wish now let's see what happens
so more time in that makeup chair then
yeah I'm okay with it because the
results are yeah I really am I mean I
don't get bored easily anyway so you
know it gives me a chance to think about
the day's work and go over my lines and
and just knowing what the end result is
means that I would stay there for as
long as possible I can't wait I can't
wait until then enjoy thank you
congratulations
[Music]